It was a weekend of absolute chaos
for what many are calling
the most promising,
one of the most promising
companies of our time, Open Air.
A top player in a revolutionary
field of artificial intelligence.
The maker
of GPG
with billions of dollars
in backing from Microsoft,
is now in turmoil
after the board fired
its co-founder
and CEO, Sam Altman, on Friday.
72 hours later,
Altman is now an employee of Microsoft,
and hundreds of workers at Openai
are threatening to follow him
if the entire board doesn't resign.
The employees are outraged,
as details of Altman's
firing remain murky
and its announcement Friday open a claim
that Altman was not sufficiently,
quote, candid with the board.
But they didn't delve into the specifics.
And now Microsoft,
a huge partner of Openai,
is coming out as a big winner.
CEO Satya Nadella has already hired
has already hired Altman himself
and some of his coworkers.
And Microsoft says
are
still committed to its
price, a record high just today.
Remember,
this is not your average
corporate reshuffle.
Openai is a powerhouse
in the tech industry, pioneering tech
that once was thought
to be the stuff of science fiction.
Openai's products
can write novels, for example,
create art,
build websites
and software from just basic descriptions
that you give.
It essentially teaches computers
to be smarter
and more humanlike than ever before,
and it can do complex tasks
that normally involve
teams of people
and do those tasks in just seconds.
Let's dig Deeper now
with CNN contributor Kara Swisher.
She's also the host of the podcast
on with Kara Swisher
and the co-host of the Pivot Podcast.
Kara, this is just a mess.
You've been talking to sources
all weekend
that we're close to all of this.
First,
tell us where things stand right now
and then step back
and give us the context
of what this means for A.I. more broadly.
You know,
I stepped away
from my phone for 5 seconds,
so I don't actually know
what's happening right now.
But obviously,
you know, the employees this
morning, which I reported,
had gotten together and written
a letter saying the board was incompetent
and they were going to leave
and work for Microsoft
if they didn't step down
and bring in a new board
and bring back Sam
and also
a guy named Greg Brockman
who left with Sam after he was fired.
And so I don't know where it stands.
Microsoft's now
going to create this new division.
It certainly has an investment in Openai,
but it doesn't
have to give it all its money
if it doesn't keep up commitments.
And it's really hard
if, you know, five, 600
people of a 750 person
staff leave a company
to keep its commitments.
So it's in a crisis
and this board has to step down.
I don't think it has any other choice.
Would that change anything, Kara,
if the board stepped down?
Is there any way to reverse course?
But it would Altman ever
come back to Openai
or as has as the die been cast?
He's over at Microsoft now.
It's a lot of this is like a
it's like a multiplayer game.
I don't know what's going to happen.
Of course,
he could come back and Microsoft
could get a board seat in control.
It could change the governance structure.
And then Sam Altman
to be fully in charge of the.
But I open a
I would just let it go and have up there
the bot the building in Phenix,
I am hoping to do.
But Microsoft apparently a victory
for the Dell
at the handle is
because its stock got killed on Friday
and now of course it rose pretty quickly
and he managed to finesse
a really bad situation
by a board that I have called,
you know, incompetent.
I agree with its employees of open
AI and does need to step aside
and how they handled this.
They might have had disagreements,
but this is not how to
run one of the most important
companies of the age at least.
Well, let's zero
in on those disagreements, Kara,
because the new CEO of Open A.I.,
the third in three days, he's
calling for an investigation
into Altman's firing.
What ultimately preceded his firing.
What was that disagreement? Do we know?
I do not.
I have tried to get that out of them.
And that's one of the issues,
the lack of transparency.
They kind of said that he was a liar,
but then didn't say what he lied about
and they wouldn't be open about it.
And then one of the people
who led the
led the firing has now vacated
and said that he supports Sam Altman.
He signed that letter, which was weird.
The chief scientist,
but he's a well regarded technologist
and he was right in the middle of it.
And then suddenly he wrote
and I'm sorry on ex this morning.
So I don't know, I guess I was joking.
It's like the Taylor Swift song.
Hi, it's me.
I'm the problem, it's me,
that kind of thing.
So I don't know what's
going to happen to this board.
There's now three people left
and we'll see what they do.
And I think if they don't step down,
I mean, you can't operate a company
without employees.
And I suspect this morning
it was 505 of them.
I suspect it's
very close to the whole company leaving.
Yeah, potentially huge implications
for one of the frontrunners
leading in this revolutionary technology.
Yeah, I think the issue was misalignment
between John and theirs
and that he wasn't
fully forthcoming about that.
You know,
they could have handled
this ten different ways
instead of just firing him,
they could have
had had a meeting or,
you know, etc., etc..
Instead, they they took this rather,
they have their very
they're very
concerned about
safety and everything else.
But then they wouldn't
give specific issues and said
it wasn't a specific safety issue either.
So who knows?
They're it's
the worst performance in the board
I've seen in a very long time.
And and it's a low bar.
Kara Swisher,
thanks so much for bringing it back
with us. Thanks a lot.